all right hey this is Pete peppers and
this is a quick video to show you how if
you've never signed up for King Kong
before you can get yourself an extra 50
gold bars for signing up so you can see
we have our game up in here we have 50
gold bars so what we'll do is open
another tab then King Tom alright so the
main page you can see we have the
different games below and we're gonna
sign up
so yeah we'll come right here put my
email address like sign up I'm going to
create a password
now that you don't have to do the same
ones that you use for your Facebook
account or anything like that you just
have to make a separate and new account
if you have linked to your facebook -
king comma for and then this won't work
because you can't disconnect it what you
do so this is a brand new account and
remember your password obviously and
then sign up
all right so now we have the console and
we are signed in you can do a lot of
things here you can change your settings
and all that later if you want to what I
did on the right side there's a little
cog over there so I clicked on it so you
can see you know you can see account
email password score and progression
sync so we have to put in the password
again the one we just made out
all right so right here it's the score
and progression sync all right so we're
gonna go ahead and click on that ready
to scroll down a little bit so this
morning for Gretchen st. nothing will be
posted to Facebook what King comm is is
it's like a separate platform the game
plays the same everything looks the same
it's just sort of like a web app that's
not played through Facebook so it's
telling us here that nothing will be
posted scores impression will be kept up
to date sync in progress and will sync
our progress between Mobile King and
Facebook and we can play anonymously
with new players on King comm so it's
basically like the same way you sync it
with your phone or your tablet except
we're doing it with the web-based
application so it's like sync our
progress
now this password is our Facebook
password so this is different than the
one we just made up but we're giving it
we're giving it permission so and then
it's gonna say it wants to see our
public profile thing that's fine and you
notice we don't get a secondary one
there that says like it wants to post a
facebook for us or anything so now it's
available on all platforms whether I
play on King Facebook around my mobile
my progress will be up-to-date all right
so I'm gonna turn on candy crush soda
and just real quick show you I'm gonna
scoot this over looks exactly the same
and you can see our photo change because
we're not in our Facebook account but
you were on level 3 and now we have 100
gold bars okay so we can play on we can
play here on King I'm not gonna show you
when you're playing level 3 and then we
can come back here and we should be able
to refresh the game and see the change
Hey
and there it is there's a 100 gold bars
so it's a one-time thing
you really can't exploit this in any way
but if you've never played on King comm
you can get an extra 50 gold bars and
it's pretty cool it's actually nice to
play on there sometimes just because you
don't have all the popups and different
things going on from Facebook you can
kind of just have a quiet experience and
it's the same as playing on your mobile
your tablet everything you do there will
be here everything you do here will be
there and vice versa so I hope this
helps you know make sure you check out
our website if you need any help with
the level or learning how to play and
use your 50 gold bars to have some fun
thanks